Bill Duke: There is a great book…there are
two books that I would recommend to people.
One is by Steven Pressfield and it’s called
THE WAR OF ART.
It’s one of the greatest books I’ve ever
read.
It helped changed my life, THE WAR OF ART.
Patrick Shen: I love…what’s his name?
Steven…do you guys know the book THE WAR
OF ART?
Is it Steven Pressfield?
Press field, right?
Jay Duplass: I do love THE WAR OF ART.
That’s the one book that I love.
UCLA Screenwriting Chair Richard Walter: THE WAR OF
ART…it’s a play on THE ART OF WAR.
Michael La Pointe: THE WAR OF ART by Steven
Pressfield, it’s a book…it’s not a book
on screenwriting.
It’s a book on getting things done.
Patrick Shen: I love THE WAR OF ART by Steven
Pressfield.
That has a great prescription for getting
through writer’s block.
You know you can sort of pull from that to
apply to any sort of challenge that you’re
meeting along the production phase.
And his advice you know, the bottom line is,
in order to beat writer’s block, you simply
have to continue writing.
And you write each and every day.
And the only way around it is to go through
it.
Michael La Pointe: Do the work as in sit down
and psychically do the work.
And then the rest of the book kind of talks
about fears and how to get past that but through
the lens of if you just do the work your fears
will go away or at least shrink, which is
true because doing something builds confidence
and confidence builds ambition.
UCLA Screenwriting Chair Richard Walter: And it’s
a pamphlet, it’s a very light piece.
You could read it while you’re waiting for
the light to change.
But it’s brilliant.
It is brilliant.
Pressfield, what he calls it is resistance.
There is this resistance sitting there and
you just have to face it and do it.
And you have to face it and you just have
to do it and you have stop trying to like
it.
Jay Duplass: I don’t subscribe to screenwriting
gurus because most of them have not written
great screenplays.
I do love THE WAR OF ART, it’s the one book
that I love (Steve Pressfield).
And I don’t think it’s a coincidence.
He’s a good screenwriter.
He’s one of the few who has written great
things.
But to me it’s not about form and it’s
not about teaching you how to do it.
It’s more about inspiring you and getting
you unstuck.
And I think that book has been super helpful
to me.
UCLA Screenwriting Chair Richard Walter: He’s gone
over the notes.
He’s thought everything through and he’s
about to start the actual rewrite and he's
just miserable contemplating actually getting
into the actual re-write.
And I said to him “I’m glad to hear it.”
Why am I glad to hear that he is miserable?
Because he’s telling me about the experiences
a real writer would have.
Only an amateur (Pressfield would out it this
way) would say that she or he can’t wait
to get into the rewrite, is delighted contemplating
getting up in the morning and working on that
script.
The contrary is the case, dreading it.
Michael La Pointe: It’s definitely…if
you are in any kind of creative field, you’re
stuck, even if you’re not stuck and you
are just starting out, it’s would probably
be more beneficial to you than the standard
screenwriting book that is going to tell you
how to do screenwriting but not really tell
you how to be creative which is like a big
thing.
There is all these books on how to manually
do screenwriting, how to break down a movie
into a 3-act structure, how do you write a
3-act structure movie, how do you do The Hero’s
Journey?
There is very little on how you psychically
do it.
There is very little (this is obviously a
very personal opinion)…the two most important
parts of filmmaking are creativity and originality.
And there are very little books on that.
You know there are kind of books in the art
vein of how do you be original?
But there is very little on filmmaking and
all that.
And that is what we admire about filmmaking.
There are great movies that are 3-act structure
Hollywood movies that nobody really likes
and there are things…like BEAST OF THE SOUTHERN
WILD that is something which is very original.
That is something that people respond to.
So it’s kind of odd that there is so many
books on this one subject and so little on
something that matters so much (to me…it’s
a personal opinion) about filmmaking.
UCLA Screenwriting Chair Richard Walter: The real writers
hate to write.
All writers that are serious writers, they
don’t like to write.
We love having written, but actually writing
is always painful “Is it good enough?
I thought yesterday what I did was…now I’m
re-reading it and it’s not as good as I’m
remembering it.
And it’s very frustrating.
Do I dare show this to anybody?
How can I expect people to (in exchange for
this) give me money so that I can put orthodontia
on my children’s teeth and so forth.
This guy said to me it was such a liberation
to read that…for him to read that all writers
hate to write and to discover that he’s
not the only that doesn’t leap from his
bed in the morning…you know…with bells
on eager beyond description to get into his
writing.
No.
We all want to put it off, delay it, defer
it, it’s that way for everybody.